بعدين احول سبعه اشهر من السيطره على
مقاطعه خرسون جنوب الشرقيه اوكرانيا وبعد
اقل من شهر ونصف على اعلان ضمها الى
اراضيها تعلن روسيا انسحاب المفاجئا الى
ما وراء نهر دنبرو تركه خلفها اهم مدن
المقاطعه ومركزها مدينه خرسون تقول موسكو
ان الخطوه تاتي في سياق اعاده تموضع
قواتها في ظل صعوبه التامين خطوط الامداد
اللازمه لجنودها لتمكينهم من الحفاظ
والدفاع عن مدينه خرسون في الاولويه الان
بالنسبه الى الجيش الروسي تحصين الخطوط
الدفاعيه على الضفه الجنوبيه من النهر
استعدادا لمعارك الشتاء القادم
لطالما اعتبرت خرسان البوابه الاستراتيجيه
لشبه جزيره القرم التي سيطرت عليها روسيا
عام 2014 وهي التي تتحكم بمعظم مصادر
الطاقه ومياه الشرب زراعه التي تغذي القرم
ومنها كانت تنطلق لا سيما في الشهور
الاولى من الحرب الهجمات الروسيه باتجاه
ميكولايف واوديسه لذلك افا ان الطرار
الجيش الروسي الى الانسحاب منها يعتبر
منعطفا اخر في مسارات الحرب الدائره في
الشرق والجنوب الشرقي لاوكرانيا خصوصا ان
الجيش الاوكراني ومنذ نجاحه في استعاده
السيطره على مناطق خارجيف لا يزال يقاتل
داخل حدود كل الاقاليم الاربعه لوجانس
ودنيازك وزابولوجيا وخرسون التي سبق
واعلنت موسكو والضمها بشكل رسميا الى
اراضيها وان كان ذلك مرتبط بشكل كبير بحجم
المساعدات الغربيه العسكريه النوعيه التي
حصل عليها في الفتره الماضيه على ان
اللافته في موقف من التطورات الميدانيه في
خرسان تشكيكها في دوافع الانسحاب الروسي
قبل ان تقول لاحقا ان الحديث عن استعاده
السيطره عليها لن يكون الا حين ترفرف
الاعلام الاوكرانيه فوق مبنى المقاطعه
مبديه في الوقت نفسه تخوفها من تحويل
الجيش الروسي لخرسون الى مدينه موت من
خلال تلغيم وتفخيف كل شيء فيها قبل
انسحابه
[موسيقى]